the goal of this video is to use this
scratch pad on khan academy that was
written by khan academy user charlotte
allen in order to get a better intuitive
sense of confidence intervals
so we're here we're dealing with a
gumball machine where a certain
proportion of the gumballs are going to
be green
and so let's say we can set that and
let's make that 60 of the gumballs are
green but let's say someone else comes
along and they don't actually know the
proportion of gumballs that are green
but they can take samples and so let's
say they take samples of 50 at a time
and so they draw a sample the sample
proportion right over here actually just
happened to be
0.6 but then they could draw another
sample this time the sample proportion
is 0.52 or 52
of those 50 gumballs happened to be
green
now you could say all right well these
are all different estimates but for any
given estimate what how confident are we
that the a certain range around that
estimate actually contains the true
population proportion
and so if we look at this tab right over
here that's what confidence intervals
are good for and in a previous video we
talked about how you calculate the
confidence interval what we want to do
is say well
there's a 95 percent chance and we get
that from this confidence level and 95
is the confidence level people typically
use and so there's a 95 percent chance
that whatever our sample proportion is
that it's within two standard deviations
of the true proportion or that the two
report the true proportion is going to
be contained in an interval that are two
standard deviations on either side of
our sample proportion
well if you don't know the true
proportion the way that you estimate the
standard deviation is with the standard
error which we've done in previous
videos and so this is two standard
errors to the right and two standard
errors to the left of our sample
proportion and our confidence interval
is this entire interval going from this
left point to this right point and as we
draw more samples you can see it's not
obvious
but our
intervals change depending on what our
actual sample proportion is because we
use our sample proportion to calculate
our confidence interval because we're
assuming whoever's doing the sampling
does not actually know the true
population proportion
now what's interesting here about this
simulation is that we can see what
percentage of the time does our
confidence interval does it actually
contain the true parameter so let me
just draw 25 samples at a time and so
you can see here that right now 93
93 of our for 93 percent of our samples
did our confidence interval actually
contain our population parameter and we
can keep sampling over here
and we can see the more samples that we
take it really is approaching that close
to 95 of the time our confidence
interval does indeed contain the true
parameter and so once again we did all
these that math in the previous video
but here you can see that confidence
intervals calculated the way that we've
calculated them actually do a pretty
good job of what they claim to do that
if we calculate a confidence interval
based on a confidence level of 95
percent that it is indeed the case that
roughly 95 of the time the true
parameter the population proportion will
be contained in that interval and i
could just draw more and more and more
samples and we can actually see that
happening every now and then for sure
you get a sample
where even when you calculate your
confidence interval the true parameter
the true population proportion is not
contained but that is the exception that
happens very infrequently 95 percent of
the time your true population parameter
is contained in that interval now
another interesting thing to see is if
we increase our sample size our
confidence interval is going to get
narrower so if we increase our sample
size we'll just make it 200. now let's
draw some samples notice now our
confidence intervals are narrower
but still because our confidence level
which was used to calculate these
intervals is still 95 percent when we
draw a bunch of samples we are still
going to get roughly 95 of the time our
confidence intervals contain our true
population proportion but five roughly
five percent of the time they don't